[Musik]
was genau jetzt willkommen bahn ein
video ja leid ich hoffe euch geht es gut
ich sitze weit unten irgendwie wartet
man ich musste irgendwie zu kurz gedacht
ich hoffe euch geht's gut sorry aber ich
habe jetzt glaube ich fünf tage nichts
hochgeladen hier in köln war er als
gamescom video days irgendwelche partys
und sonstwas und irgendwie habe ich es
einfach nicht geschafft ich habe mir
kommen günstige mal kurz diese fünf tage
urlaub oder so oder so sagen das war auf
jeden fall habe ich aber anfang der
woche gesehen das video wo ich mir
sondern amazon überraschungspaket
gestellt habt ich habe ja gesagt ja
passt auch bei keiner rund 15.000 likes
oder so oder wenn ihr bock habt schon
etwas meine kommentare bestelle ich mal
so ein fettes amazon überraschungspaket
für 50 euro und ich habe mir jetzt
kurzfristig gedacht einkommen dann
machst es einfach richtig und bestellt
sie nicht irgendwann ein paket bei 50
euro sondern gleich eins für 100 euro
altertum also das ist echt mega groß und
das ist auch ziemlich schwer
stellt euch mal kurz die dimension von
diesem paket zeigen
die leute das hier ist das paket
wir nennen es ein paar thomas und ja an
sich besteht das heutige video darin
dieses paket auszupacken ja heute ich
würde sagen weil 30.000 beschäftigten
das nächste amazon überraschungspaket
für 1000 euro
und wir packen das jetzt noch
[Musik]
alter sie haben ja viele leute da das
video jetzt auch nicht nur halbe stunde
lang gehen soll würde ich sagen wir
packen es einfach im schnelldurchlauf
aus und das was wirklich witzig ist
freilich rein in den rest halt nicht so
hässlich ist das gar nicht vielleicht
könnten jetzt schon gut vorstellen in
der wohnung solche bilder die sind an
sich feiern oder und noch ein foto ja
super
okay machen wir weiter wo zwei asset
deko gecko zwecken weit so einfach
[Musik]
hausschuhe 35 ist was für dich bei mir
läuft der schuhriese 730 schreibt in die
kommentare
die werden verlost eine luftpumpe und
spaß das ist alles voll mit dem kurier
brauche ich nicht keine ahnung wo das
stinkt so wir machen weiter mobil stand
was ist das alter egal was ist denn
alter leute schlecht dass man ich weiß
das
[Musik]
er warte gibt immer kurz irgendwie musik
wenn man kurz gucken ob die ob die gut
sind
er ist der richtige mann besitzt so ein
sehr veränderbar
alles wo die qualität es schon hart
scheiße wie altavista das hier ist eine
lichterkette mit herzen als alles und
herzen
willst du die haben das ist finde ich
einfach glück mal noch ein bild oder ist
es ja echt mega gut das können wir als
platz wegnehmen oder was ist das
aber ganz ehrlich so was kann man
gebrauchen ich erst mal bei uns auf dem
kühlschrank meinen eltern werden
begeistert sein high school musical
also was soll ich schon immer machen das
ist radierungen
da muss irgend was können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ohne box hier können wir stift rein tun
ich hasse es wenn außer mir nichts süßes
im hause und wärmflasche zwei euro
kostet die jungs 15 euro das wäre sonst
das stimmt alles
malta da würde ich niemals aus trinken
noch ist das wollen wir jetzt ins watt
stellen alter was ist das
das können wir auch gebrauchen wenn ich
mal hier wieder in einer anderen bein
schwört sich das einfach für ein gebiss
der rest das oben besetzt hatten
schatz ersatz des in tempus das kommt
echt so viel scheiße auf diesem planeten
das ist ja so hatte das paket ist jetzt
nach gefühlten halben stunde endlich mal
leer so fünf von den sachen kann man auf
jeden fall gebrauchen den rest nicht
weil aktienpaket ist aber wirklich
dieser hut
[Applaus]
ihr habt dann werde ich auch sagen ich
schaffe das nicht gefallen lassen und
[Musik]
vielleicht
mindestens morgen sind am morgen ist man
die substanz ist das überhaupt ein